it is black history month eight news now
is recognizing
influential black men and women who
helped shape or design our city
yeah this one's interesting brian our
reporter kate houston showing us the
story behind the guardian angel
cathedral
that's a church on desert inn in las
vegas boulevard and its trail blazing
architect
paul revere williams for decades the
guardian angel cathedral has stood as a
striking contrast to the evolving las
vegas strip
and the modern resorts that tower over
it for a city that is renowned for
building and imploding building and
imploding
and then all of a sudden you have you
have this and
it it is still beautiful today as it was
then
paul revere williams built the cathedral
in 1963 to give strip
workers an easier way to go to mass its
unique a-frame design has drawn in both
locals and tourists
he was very considerate about the client
and actually what were they using
the building for how could it be
practical but beautiful at the same time
william's career was taking off during a
time of segregation and racism which
impacted the way he worked he learned
how to sketch upside down knowing some
clients would not want to sit near him
despite these challenges he persevered
going on to design
more than 2 thousand buildings including
mansions for celebrities and
local hotels he was a
a very proud and a very focused
but very much aware of his clients
aware of the requirements and wanting to
make a difference
for how people lived for nearly 60 years
the cathedral has been home to countless
weddings baptisms and life events
all a part of the legacy williams leaves
behind
kate houston 8 news now we are also
highlighting local african-americans who
inspire
others in our community you can watch
our special sunday february 14
at 6 30 p.m terrific story there from
kate houston
really a rich history right around the
corner denise learning something new
every day